tis the season to be jolly in the hope
that everyone is enjoying their holiday
so far today I'm excited to finally be
bringing you episode 1 of our dark world
series for those of you who have an
aversion to strong language you have
been warned this video may not be for
you for this is not a story of happy
holiday spirit for those who do have a
particular interest in our friend
Krampus this is going to be a long story
I advise you to pour yourself a drink
get a snack and make yourself as
comfortable as possible
while you enjoy some holiday horror dark
world episode 1 Krampus night that's him
eat a bit early I didn't understand why
some I used the curse word big deal at
her dance where hundreds of times and no
one sent him to bed early
Anya had been allowed to stay up
although I suppose she had thrown up a
little I would have thrown up a little
too if him and I could stay up and wait
for Santa
I'd always waited for Santa but each
time a spell would come over me and I
would sink into sleep this would be the
tenth time ten times even cats had less
lives than that i huffed my way up the
stairs stamping my feet trying to get
mum and dad to feel sorry for me as they
cuddled my sister it wasn't happening
there they sat there like two bears God
in their cub and there was no room for
me I wondered what sort of trouble I'd
been right now if I swore in anger but I
chose not to well not at them I
whispered it to myself quietly for grin
on my face [ __ ] as I got into bed I
stayed at the window opposite me where I
could see the snowflakes drifting in the
wind I wondered whether if I said they
were my nails digging into my thigh I
could stay up and watch Santa's sleigh
soaring across the sky but then I
thought about the possibility of Santa
sneaking up on the other end of the
house I wouldn't forgive myself if he
crept down a chimney while I was staring
out the window I glanced at the clock
and noticed it was nearing 7 o'clock but
that seemed a little too early for Santa
to start delivering presents he'd
probably come in a thick of night or
maybe even the early hours of the
morning I sure had a long wait and
nothing to do I began to get restless
[ __ ]
I said out loud again but not loud
enough that they'd hear me downstairs I
didn't see the big deal of what I said
I swallow I didn't hurt no one mom and
said it was a bad word but what's so bad
about [ __ ] I'd said the word so many
times in my mind that it didn't really
make sense to me anymore
I turned on my side and sat with my
hands crossed painfully around my leg
good luck falling asleep lay there I
told myself
there was no whales missing Santa this
time I wouldn't let myself miss him ever
again I closed my eyes for just a second
just to test whether I could possibly
fall asleep or so uncomfortable I could
hear the sounds of my sister laughing
laughing like she hadn't thrown up at
all mom and dad will laugh not that I -
probably tickling her that they used to
tickle me I felt the grip around my leg
begin to loosen and though I knew I
should have lifted my head up off the
pillow I didn't the sound of my sister's
laughs adjourned out into silence and
pretty soon after that I had dozed off
when I awoke I woke with a start I
sprang forward so hard that I thought I
pulled something in my neck it was dark
outside darker than had been before so
dark I couldn't even see the moon my
heart was beatin fast though not with
the usual excitement that I had on this
night no it was dread dread that I'd
failed again and let's the clock until
was 12 minutes past midnight
perhaps the latest I've ever been up I
guess that in itself was exciting I wake
had this time breaking the rules
[ __ ] I whispered to myself in giggled
giggled are not only sworn while I was
up past my bedtime I hope Santa hadn't
cumbia I kicked the duvet off my bed and
was about to spring downstairs but then
I heard it the ringing of bells no it
couldn't be my heart was thumping again
this time it was true excitement as I
ran to the window I couldn't see him not
in the dark but I could hear he sleigh I
was so bad at controlling my excitement
that I started jumping around the room
quietly though because I knew if dad
came in then he would just ruin the fun
the bells on Santa's sleigh weren't
quiet but I imagined he had parked and a
roof who was now shimmying down the
chimney I had to see him just to get a
glimpse of him my friends were beginning
to think that maybe just maybe Santa
wasn't real at all but if I saw him with
my own eyes I could know for myself he
had to be real he was real he was
downstairs right now it made me wonder
why I was even stalling
aghast eagerly I carefully open adorn
rounded the corner descended on the
first set of steps narrowly avoiding the
creaky floorboard past my sister's room
I only had a few more steps to go before
I could peek him between the banister
rail and spot him by the tree but then
my sister's door opened [ __ ] I sighed
fully thinking it was my father standing
there and then I realized I'd have been
in double trouble because I swore again
dawn came on his voice Shh I spun round
and schuster she stood there rubbing her
eyes and yawning loudly - what are you
doing up you're gonna be in trouble she
said of a slight grin what are you doing
up i hissed at her you're going to be in
trouble - mum said I can get up and go
to the toilet when I want to because I'm
sick she poked her tongue out at me I
would have pushed her over if I knew
she'd fall in silence but that was too
risky I just lifted my hand and gave her
the middle finger a boy at school had
called it the bird but I wasn't too sure
what it meant he'd gotten in trouble for
using it I thought maybe it might have
hurt rner in some way what does that
mean she sneered at me it means and I
looked at my finger uncertainly it means
something bad oh yeah she did it back at
me go back to bed
I turned away and continued creeping
down the stairs I'm gonna tell mom in
the morning she said / yawn and then
slithered back into her room stupid girl
I said as I carried on down the stairs I
made it to the bottom of the stairs and
I could hear shuffling in the next room
he wasn't being as quiet as I thought he
might be but then again I guess I'd be
clumsy mm Santa the daughter delivery
was ajar as I peered in I could see our
Christmas tree all lit up with green and
red decorations strewn about it the
lights around the branches flickered I
could smell the festive aroma ah I heard
Santa bark as he tripped over something
stabbed my [ __ ] toe I'd heard that
word you used before but I didn't know
what it meant it sure sounded worse than
[ __ ] though I thought about turning away
creeping back up to bed as I let Santa
get on with it but I had to see him so
why did I feel so scared all of sudden
past the time of year this is he was
still grunting swear to god this is the
last one no that couldn't be Santa could
it I push the door open a little more
open to catch a glimpse of him I so
desperately wanted to see but the figure
even more as I heard him Gosselin liquor
from dad
my hand was shaking as I reached out for
the doorknob again and all of a sudden I
felt the need to pee I pushed the door
an inch and then another and then
another until the door was moving back
on its own to reveal the rest of the
room he stood though his back to me
chugging down a bottle of brown booze
had died normally say for special
occasions
I'd sipped it once but it really burned
my throat and since then I kept away
from him how my dad drank it at all I'll
never know but scenes tend to knock it
back like it was Ribena was unsettling
he swayed to the left and then to the
right and before long he was buckling
over his own feet fallen flat on his
face
santé aghast he looked up immediately
and just for a moment I thought I saw
that jolly red face that I was so used
to seeing but no instead those a cold
cruelest to his eyes as they bore into
me his beard was wet of alcohol and he
let out an angry snarl you can't he
barked as he thrust his big finger at me
I wanted to run I tried to run back
upstairs but somehow I was frozen to the
spot come here he growled as he
staggered to his feet I was shaking now
I didn't know what I had done wrong all
I knew was that Santa was mad at me and
now now I was in even more trouble it
was more than just trouble though I
could see the noise Santa hobbled
towards me
he's fists clenched and he throws you
her cheeks looking like they were filled
of lava I tried to move my legs and Dodd
upstairs mum and dad will be mad at me
for being up so late
but it had to be better than what Santa
had in mind his eyebrows were buried
deep down and his eyes were red like he
hadn't slept at all he moved quick all
of a sudden grabbing me by the t-shirt
and yanking me forward he pulled me so
hard that I need we fell in the same way
he did there's always one flippin kid
who can't stay asleep he hiccuped he
wasn't keeping his voice down either any
second now my parents would come running
down and I'd be in for it I broke free
of him and tried to shuffle my way into
the Christmas tree out of his wrath but
my body didn't respond I ended up just
fooling on my butt and then all I could
do was just stare up at him hugging my
knees as tightly as I could as he
stuffed another cookie in his mouth you
naughty bastard to make my work longer
than it needs to be why can't you just
be good and he stopped to pull out the
longest list that I've ever seen it
spilled out of his pocket and he quietly
mumbled a few names as he read down the
list until he found my name Dom he
sneered before crumbling up the list and
stuffing it in his pocket
yes you've been naughty haven't you no
Santa I managed to squeak swearing he
shook his head flipping off your sister
staying up late these are terrible
things for a child to do I'm sorry Santa
I cried out and I genuinely meant it too
I didn't mind being on the naughty list
in fact I didn't mind not receiving
presents at this point I just didn't
want my parents to know and I didn't
want Santa to be mad at me you're going
to have to be punished Dominic he told
me the faintest sound of enjoyment in
his otherwise gruff voice punished I
could barely get the word so please
don't tell my mom and dad your mum and
dad he choked her laughter [ __ ] that I'm
not letting your [ __ ] parents steal
this punishment I have a special friend
for that who I shuddered was one of the
elves gonna come out and beat me what
took you so bloody long Santa said but I
realized he wasn't talking to me and
instead speaking at something that must
have been right behind me I looked
behind me and saw something standing
there well I say stand in but it was
hunched over
leerin down at me like I was his prey
the skin around his face was wrinkled
sagging and he had too thick a set of
yellow stained teeth drool pulled down
the side of his lips and there was a
long wispy beard that blended in with a
dark gray fur on his chest he had curved
horns jutting out from his forehead both
of them looked like that was stained in
blood his hands were massive of long
skeletal fingers and there were black at
the nail as he stood there breathing I
could hear the air being sucked out
through his nose though struggling like
there were blocks of bogies stuck up
there he had no eyes just two Dark Void
his eyes should have been filled with
crimson chains will hung around his
wrists tightly wrapped around his chest
and hanging loosely around his hip each
time he moved he made a jingling sound
eerily similar to Santa's sleigh the
same sound I heard upstairs
I screamed or at least I thought I did
but there was no sound automatically I
found myself calling to my hands and
knees as I tried to sculpt onto the tree
but the creature man thing was faster
and clutched at my ankle which giant
hand I shouted for my mum and dad as he
yanked me out but they didn't show up
baubles from the Christmas tree came
raining down around me but still they
didn't come rushing downstairs to my
rescue
I wondered if they'd be down here if it
was on you being attacked
I tried to wrench my leg free but before
long there were golden sticks in the
creatures hand and it lifted them high
above its head Guerra on my bed Santos
looked as he started to open another
bottle scratching at his crotch as he
did gonna need a pest in a minute the
sticks came down hard against my leg not
once but at least a dozen times the
creature or whatever it was had a
gruesome smile on his face like he truly
was happy causing me pain I winced of
every strike frontally trying to free
myself as he began to twist my ankle
stop I cried out please I'll be good
I'll be good
and you won't swear anymore Santa
squatted nearby he dropped some kind of
pink color pills and was having
difficulty finding them even though they
were right in front of him I swear I
promise I won't I begged and I thought
it was best not to mention that he spent
the better part of our encounter with a
potty-mouth himself they sure don't make
LSD like they used to he muttered to
himself as he found purchase on the
pills
Krampus take him to the lair I don't
believe a single word out of this little
bastards mouth no I screamed I didn't
even know what the lair was or even who
Krampus was but neither sounded good
Krampus or whatever he was pulled out a
sack with one hand and began whipping it
into the air until it unfolded then with
his other hand wrapped around my ankle
he lifted me up like I weighed nothing
and tossed me into the bag and then I
was falling
zealots the whole pack of them all have
spat over the railing but I didn't think
they deserved it a dozen of them had
gathered in a narrow streets below
frolicking in the snow like an unruly
bunch of teenagers you wouldn't have
guessed that down there they were grown
men and women each one of them done in
dark fur around their shoulder covering
their entire body if he looked back and
forth real quick you might have mistaken
them for a bunch of wild animals rolling
about in the snow but sooner or later
you'd see their gruesome costumes
most of them Andorian horns and bloody
fangs I hated them not because of the
racket they were making down below but
because of how ignorant they were like I
said I would have spat over the railing
but I didn't want to waste it on them
one of them was rolling around in the
snow making some kind of snow angel
whilst another word jingling chains
around his wrist
the others were skulking behind cars
sticking up on people who like me were
either just too tired from a hard day's
work to humor their stupid game or he
was simply just too mature one of them
jumped in front of an elderly man's face
an elderly man shrieked dropped his bags
and started screaming at the top of his
lungs not too far away from him
one of them struck a woman with a birch
stick they were Carrie but she too
didn't see the funny side to it and
started smacking him with her handbag
idiot I muttered and watch as the smoke
spilled out from my mouth billowing into
the air Cass
Arno called from the next room is the
krampuslauf still going on what kind of
stupid question was that I crossed my
hands around the lukewarm coffee mug
that I still held and leaned in close
over the balcony contemplating whether
it was worth forsaking the mug just to
hit one of them of course it was still
going on it never flippin ended December
was infected with fiends like the ones
below dressing up as a monster that they
had no right to if they knew if only
they knew the dangers of that thing then
well I didn't know what no one had ever
believed me yeah I'm watching them I
called back at Arno my room mate who I'm
sure only spoke to me because he liked
the sound of his own voice
good he stumbled out onto the balcony in
for a moment how do I look my head post
for a split second the air had been
sucked out of me I didn't quite know
where to look at first but I was soon as
slaves that I shadowed black holes it
had four eyes its horns were just as I
remembered one of them crooked and
broken and the other drizzled in blood I
felt my hand twitching by
side reaching for the nearest weapon a
plant in a pot he was back after all
this time he'd finally come back I swore
that I'd be ready for him but there I
was my lukewarm coffee one hand reaching
for my heart to make sure it was still
there powerless Cass I thought I heard
honor as Krampus stood there in a
doorway
his hands on his hips as his knees
worked back and forth in some
strange-looking dance it doesn't know
that bad does it it took me a moment you
have to forgive me
if you knew what I had seen you'd know I
needed that moment I stood there blankly
like some stupid deer caught in the
headlights of a car to Sun to move and
yet almost too aware of the impending
danger I had to force my door open
resting against my own lips until the
words spilled out in anger you [ __ ]
I roared and lunged at him snatching him
by the throat and knocking that
god-awful mask off his face his scrawny
and feeble face looking more panicked
than I ever did I told you in an ad when
you first moved in here that I wanted no
god damn Krampus [ __ ] in this building I
spoke slowly pepper in each of my words
of as much venom as I could I wanted him
to know my frustration wanted him to
know my pain but it fell on deaf ears
much as it always did okay Cass
he laughed nervously and managed to slip
out of my grip let's not get too carried
away here it's just a costume
Krampus isn't even real it's all just a
made-up story you don't know the words
you weren't there was sure to follow but
I quickly realized what a Luna must have
sounded like and chose to sip my coffee
instead when are you going to let that
go he said as he stuffed his mosque in
his outrageous horns under his arm
you're 35 in a few months and you're
still scared of Krampus maybe you should
see someone maybe I should see you out
of this flat I thought to say with one
eye twitchin you want to see creepy [ __ ]
Cass he said as he disappeared inside
only to reappear of a tablet in his hand
look at this he passed it to me and I
took it reluctantly as I stared down at
the image of what looked like the front
cover of a book a warrior flying a white
horse into the path of a fire-breathing
monster Greek mythology explained a
deeper look at no not that he swiped the
image away that's just some [ __ ] ad
here look at the article man kills wife
of bare hands after finding her eaten
his son Jesus
what the [ __ ] is this I looked up at him
and he's giddy expression messed up
right
apparently the dudes been saying it's
some man-eating spirit or something this
is disgusting I shoved the tablet back
in his hand in fact I find you quite
repulsive at the moment if you don't
mind me saying you're really pulling my
heartstrings here Cass he said of a
gaudy laugh I just looked at him blankly
trying to stop myself from punching him
in the face I mean sure we want the
closest people but I'd made the mistake
of telling him about well the incident
to his credit he hadn't laughed at me
but it was obvious that he didn't
believe me either
you wouldn't dress up as an actual din
psychopath if someone had been
traumatized by a lumberjack so why was
it okay to dress up as that monster
knowing the effect it would have on me
I'm gonna go enjoy the festivities he
said was a nod of his head you sure you
don't want to come I glanced up at the
sky and thought was high time I got into
bed the Sun would be rising soon and I
had no intention of face in it you know
working at that Club at these unsociable
hours is gonna have an effect on you
Otto said although his voice was muffled
by his mosque as he hobbled back inside
you want to make sure that you're
getting enough with him indeed you know
I don't think I've ever seen you guard
in the daytime no wonder you're so pale
go to hell I muttered back at him as I
poured the last few drops of my coffee
over the railing I'm already there he
called back as he hoped to the door he's
joined claw-like feet I wondered if it
was worth making another coffee given
that I was going to lay in bed awake
anyway but I thought better of it I wait
until I saw our know emerge outside in
the street below and watch as he joined
the krampuslauf
that wretched festival idiot I muttered
as I made my way to bed
I woke up of a start half expectant to
see my bedroom ceiling instead of the
sparkling dagger like icicles hanging
above me threatening to fall I let out a
shriek and though I hadn't meant to I
sounded like a little girl
it was dark here but a silver light
spilled in through the cracks of the icy
walls where am I
I wondered as I scuttled back against a
damp wall my knees held tightly against
my chest I was freezing cold and each
time I let out a breath gray smoke
billowed out of my mouth like a chimney
I was shivering
my teeth clattering as I began to snivel
at the nose I wanted my mum I would have
taken my dad at this point wherever I
was it sure wasn't home I thought back
to Santa Claus and there was a moment of
elation as I remembered the center I
thought I knew but then that moment was
ripped away scrunched up like a ball of
paper and set on fire
the Santa I'd seen the real Santa
appeared in my mind all drunken swearing
and worst of all that was the only Santa
that ever remember from that point on my
trousers were damp not from wetting
myself although that might still happen
but from the snow in which I sat I wish
I had a jacket or maybe even a portable
heater I'd seen mum use a blow dryer
which I thought would come in really
handy right about now
I sat there in my jungle book pajamas
getting colder and wetter by the second
my bare toes tingling as the cold air
wrapped around them something echoes
through the cavern at least I thought it
was a cabin looking to the right I only
saw a wall of blue ice some of which was
a little reflective and I could see
hundreds of tiny faces staring back I
looked like I wanted to cry and to be
honest I felt like that too I looked at
a left and the Kevon extended further
along the floor of slippery ice hidden
by a carpet of settled snow and beyond
that there was just darkness the pockets
of lights spilled in through the cracks
in the ceiling here and there [ __ ] I
trembled I wish I'd never said the word
but there I was again I thought back to
the monster that had grabbed me I felt a
horribly icy chills from through me
Santa had called him Krampus but I'd
never heard any stories or songs about
him mom and dad surely would have said
something wouldn't they he had to have
been evil had to have been like one of
the monsters I'd seen under my bed but
they will know when they are is ugly or
gruesome besides dad always scared them
away Krampus though Krampus was bigger
than that even though he looked hunched
over and while dad was strong he'd never
been able to lift me up by one leg and
toss me into a sack like that I still
couldn't understand how I got here one
minute I was falling and the next I woke
up here I suppose I wasn't going to find
answers sitting around here waiting for
a rescue even though my God told me to
stay put I slowly got to my feet to move
like a pigeon across the snow and
further into the cavern perhaps there
was an exit up ahead surely there had to
be an exit didn't there my feet crunched
in this
and for the first time in my life I
realized how important shoes were mum
was always telling me to wear my
slippers whenever I went outside and now
I know why it was like stepping on
spikes the ice and the snow working
together to stab at the back of my feet
cramping until they were ready than
anything I've ever seen before something
rocked the cavern then it had me pinned
to my spot breath held tight as it
washed over me
it sounded like laughter but not just
any laughter an evil sort of laugh that
that came from deep within someone's
throat someone or something I thought I
saw a shadow move across the wall of a
hunched horned figure but when I
shrieked backwards I realized that it
wasn't moving at all just the rock
nothing more they laughter still bounce
off the walls their crane throughout the
cavern and back the way it came until it
droned out quieting until eventually
silent I wanted to cry in fact no I was
crying tears roll down my face but I
couldn't feel them I think some of them
may have frozen on my cheek I wondered
if my parents were going to come running
out of the darkness to hold me and carry
me home and whether or not they even
noticed I was gone at all I bet it was
Anya that I noticed straight away
probably would have realized she was in
danger long before she could have been
brought to this place it had me
clenching my fists as I thought about it
they loved her more be brave I told
myself as I force one foot in front of
the other there was no one to hug or
hold me here but maybe when I got out I
could find mum and dad and then then
they'd love me again
surely maybe if they saw me come back
from this icy place all by myself then
maybe maybe they'd be proud of me and
love me again maybe I'd even shove Anya
to one side just like they did with me
and I'd get all the attention again it
made my heart beat of excitement again
and I guess that was the best I could
hope for
as I was brought back to reality by a
whiff of cold air I hoped that I didn't
hear that flirty laughter again as I
moved forward I crept slowly partly in
case I stumbled in the dark and partly
because I didn't want to run into
Krampus if he was down here there was no
way I was gonna outrun him with my
frozen feet if I listened carefully I
could still hear that thirty laughter
but quieter now I could linger in echo
it made me shiver even more I must have
walked at least twenty minutes before I
could go no further
my legs are frozen and I could barely
bend them at the knee without almost
fallen over I was about to collapse on
my face
but then I noticed something in a near
distance what looked like a yellow light
or switched on has by itself and hanging
there from the icy ceiling was an actual
light bulb hung by a thin line of tinsel
I felt like I was trespassing all of a
sudden as I crept closer below the light
bulb was an old rotten desk tucked into
a secluded corner papers were littered
here and there some of them in large
piles I could teach his desk and others
pinned against the icy walls as I got
closer I could see a damp noticeboard
hung crookedly against the wall were
pictures of children all around the same
age as me none of which was smiling but
instead quite the opposite I carefully
reached my shaking hand out towards the
desk and took one of the papers from the
stack Nautilus 20-18 it read and was
followed by a list of names I said the
paper back where I found it and took to
study in the photos in more detail in
one larger photo that had been stored in
a frame
santé stood with his hands by his hips
as children sat around him all of them
crying at first I didn't understand why
but then I saw the bottle of liquor in
his hand as well as a shaded figure that
lingered over his shoulder with change
draped around its wrist I noticed that
that this drawer hadn't been shot
properly and my gut told me to leave it
alone but I couldn't resist peering
inside I took a step closer to the desk
sliding my feet towards it until I reach
the knob on the drawer
I could barely fill any of my fingers
let alone get a decent grip but when I
did I was able to pull the drawer open
so I could see what lay inside it was
just coal small black shards of coal it
didn't make sense right away who even
kept cold in the desk come to think of
it who even had a desk fitted in the
place like this I pushed the door closed
and was about to carry on further in the
cavern when I heard something that had
my spine II straighten you shouldn't be
here Kim a voice behind I didn't want to
turn around but the voice didn't sound
too threatening I spun around only to
see another boy who looked like he was
the same age as me he too was wearing
pajamas but at least he had slippers he
didn't look like the cold bothered him
as much as it bothered me but I could
tell him that we were expression on his
face that he was scared he kept looking
fur into the cabin and then back at me
he's panicked eyes grown wider and wider
quickly he hissed hide what I just
looked at him blankly as he dove behind
a snow dog trench
one I think he might have made himself
hide he hissed again
he's coming who I frowned but I should
have known the air became suddenly stale
and from the darkness ahead I could hear
the rattling of chains the boy had not
disappeared entirely behind his trench
and I would have joined him if I didn't
think he'd kick me out so I doubled back
to the desk got down on all fours and
scurried underneath
I only realized how loud I was breathin
when I saw him emerge ahead of me The
Hunchback figure with dark wet fur and
two crooked horns that stuck out from
his head its face was as wrinkly as I
remembered only now it looked like it
had gray veins travelling through its
cheeks disappeared into the white forest
of his beard I shivered at the sight of
him hoping to God that he didn't come
towards a desk
he began sniffing the air grunting to
himself as he staggered forward head
swiveling left and right in his hand he
had the same sack that he used to
capture me but now it looked too empty
as he trotted on the ground behind him
his eyes scan the cavern through dark
pits of nothing I in each and every
crevice in the vicinity
he stopped sniffing the air like he
smelled something
I wondered it feels my fear he glanced
over my direction and I shut my eyes
Tencent every muscle in my body in the
hopes that he didn't see me but could I
really be so lucky I knew I needed to
open my eyes for if I didn't I wouldn't
be able to see him coming at me then
again maybe that was a good thing a part
of me wanted to keep my eyes shut
forever another part of me wanted to dig
my fingers into my ears so I didn't hear
the awful racking of the chains and the
ghastly sounds that escaped his mouth I
swallowed back my fear I took a quiet
deep breath and then I forced my eyes
open only to see Krampus staring
directly at me I tried to move tried to
run from out under the desk and back the
way I'd came but I was paralyzed I
started to breathe heavier whimpering is
my world of Tears
I tried forcing myself to move but
nothing worked
I was stuck under the desk trembling at
the sight of Krampus whose black Mouth
was now bent into a smile he moved slow
chains rattle as he stomped his giant
feet in the snow he began to straighten
in his stride and he shadows spread
before him in a long line of darkness he
abandoned the sack as it fell limp in
the snow and rubbed his massive hands
together smiling even more I tried push
him back against the wall as the feedom
returned to my bones but it was too late
no matter how much I pushed
instead there was no escaping walls I
expected to happen for some magic
daughter open and for me to go tumbling
through I was about to shoot up and try
and run but the desk had become more of
a prison than the hiding place I had to
crawl out from underneath it first and
by the time I did Krampus would have
grabbed me so I sat there like a
helpless insect in the wake of a spider
i clenched my fist but what was I gonna
do box of Krampus he began grunting
excitedly the gruesome face came closer
and closer as he lowered himself to my
level I shut my eyes and curled up
tightly into a little ball as he reached
under the desk
he's nails scratching against the wood
but then he made a disgruntled sound I
opened my eyes and saw him looking back
at the trench where the other boy was
hiding and just like that he left me
alone as he stalks over to the other boy
no the boy screamed Krampus was
deceptively fast I didn't know how he
knew the boy was there but he did he
lunged at him stomping through a snow
peas giant feet and grabbed the boy by
the neck I saw the boy squirm legs and
hands flapping as he reached for the air
it might have been selfish but I was
relieved it wasn't me my body moved on
its own without even thinking I'd
crawled out from under the desk and
bolted further into the darkness but not
before I heard the other boy's neck snap
and the crunch of the bone echo
throughout the cavern I woke with a
start drenched in my own sweat you think
when you dreamt the same dream over and
over and over again you'd get used to it
but I never did each summer woke from
those accursed dreams I found myself
panting for breath sometimes even
retching red light from that neon sign
outside my flat flooded the room and the
constant humming buzz that a sign
emitted would see to it that I would not
sleep another wink I looked at the clock
and saw it was 3:00 a.m. time to feed
then I thought I stretched as I got out
of bed and lumbered my way to the door
dragging my feet as I did you might
think that eating at 3:00 a.m. is a
weird habit but when I get my urges for
sustenance I get them hard you wouldn't
like me when I'm hungry and no I'm not
talking about those edgy girls who get
hangry if they haven't had a meal in an
hour or two no I'd straight up take a
bite out of you and drain you until
there's nothing left
such was the way of things I didn't
bother turning the lights on as I felt
my way around the kitchen it wasn't
until I found the fridge I noticed the
note on the door I put the cranberry
juice in the bottom
back cold just the way you like it a
thanks honor I scrunch up the note and
toss it behind me and guess you have
your uses
I didn't bother pouring myself a glass I
just tore up in the carton and chugged
it down moaning as I felt the smooth
liquid christened my throat and still
run down inside me I still remember the
day that Arno tried my cranberry juice
and spat it back out complaining that it
was the worst thing he'd ever tasted the
fact that he'd wasted a mouthful had me
twitch him of disgust but I had to
forgive him he didn't know how important
my cranberry juice was to me I spilled a
bit of it down the side of my face as I
drained the contents of the carton I
came up for air it's been a bit more
down my neck can over my top before
going back for more you wouldn't
understand
it wasn't just ordinary cranberry juice
after all it was well I guess it doesn't
really matter once I'd finished the cart
and I scrunch it up with my fists and
lobbed it at the bin Anna was probably
still out with those hooligans in the
Krampus loaf and was likely at some bar
in a town getting drunk any second now
I'd get that drunken text that he was
lost and I'd have to race to drive him
home well this time he could go ahead
and sleep in the early way drowning in
his own vomit all I cared I was still
pissed off that he had gone ahead and
dressed up as that hideous creature
after everything I told him I swore to
God that if he returned wearing that
costume I'd rip off those horns that he
so proudly wore and plunged them into
his neck I staggered my way across the
kitchen over into the living room where
I tripped over my slippers the damn
things were never where I expected I
felt for them with my feet and found
purchase on one of them but the other
must have gone under the couch when I
managed to eventually pull it out it was
heavier than it should have been and had
a moist ewokese scent to it worst thing
about it was I knew that smell in fact I
knew it all too well my heart thundered
as I ran to the light switch I punched
it so hard I was sure I made a hole in
the wall but as a light swept the room
my attention was drawn to my slippers I
shrieked as I dropped them to the floor
and as they hit the ground black
fragments of coal spilled out no I
backed away from them no it can't be
my skin was flush of goose pimples and I
suddenly found it hard to breathe
I backed further away from the slippers
unable to take my eyes away from them as
I began to quake in fear I fear that I
long since forgotten in that moment I
was a little girl again and there's
nothing I could do to escape the feeling
that everything around me was closing in
that's when I heard him I tried to turn
around and my first instinct was to make
a fist and swinging as hard as I could
but I couldn't I could hear his tongue
clicking in his mouth I could hear the
chains rattling by his sight I could
hear the struggle when he's nasally
breath I could hear everything that I'd
heard all those years ago
all of it preserved in my memory forever
and now it was here again for real this
time
oh no I started oh no this isn't [ __ ]
funny but honor didn't reply as I turned
to face him
oh no I said again but honors Moss
didn't have those dark hollow eyes and
the black Gorge like wrinkles at this
thing did honor wasn't as tall either
and he didn't have the same fierce in
girth oh no stop it I continued on
anyway hoping that somehow it was him
and I wasn't about to relive my worst
nightmare all over again all over for
[ __ ] sake
I begged still hoping that he would
start laughing in that horrible
irritating way that he did but the only
thing that happened was Krampus opening
his sack as he came at me of a mad and
wheezy cackle I didn't stop running even
though I felt my legs were sore my feet
scream at me in pain I wanted to look
over my shoulder but I was scared just
in case I saw Krampus baron and after me
I couldn't hear him on my tail and that
was good enough for me
but it didn't help me get out of this
place all I knew I was headin around in
a circle and any second now I'd round a
corner and end up back by the desk of
Krampus waiting for me there was a
rickety bridge ahead of me that swayed
in the draft but I didn't stop to
consider the risk
I helped him the bridge and dotted
across it even though the panel's
beneath my feet gave way and birkoff
disappeared down below into the dark
Gorge I held onto the ropes at the side
stride in my way across only to trip a
hole my own feet towards the end I
smacked the snow hard inhaling a bunch
of it as I choked for air I must have
looked like a flopping fish as I rolled
onto my back desperately trying to get
up I couldn't see Krampus as I caught my
breath scanning the area of my heart
holding herself against my chest the
bridge creaked as it swayed back and
forth and the wind whistled through the
cavern nipping at my signs I had to
swallow and there was a moment of
silence but then my breasts are back
breathing cold vapor like a dragon might
have breathed fire I knew I couldn't sit
here long
Krampus had seen me and while the other
kid bought me some time I didn't know
how long I had I didn't want to think
about him anyway like
I felt responsible for his death there
were tears in my eyes even though I
didn't know who he was
I wondered it feels like me sneaking out
of bed to see Santa only to find what I
had found I slammed my fist into the
snow before climb into my shaky feet and
dad once told me he could die from a
thing called frostbite but I didn't know
if I had it or not how do you even die
from frostbite anyway do you just fall
over and stop living or was there some
sort of sign my hands had on blue but my
feet looked like they were turning black
I knew that couldn't have been a good
sign I turned around and started heading
further into the cavern where I found a
torch light flickering in a dark orange
light sprang ahead lighting the way into
what felt like a warmer more inviting
area of this strange place for one the
snow was gone and in its stead as a hard
lurking floorboard all of which was laid
quickly out of place rusty nails stuck
out like warped fingers in the wood and
in the gaps of the broken boards was
black dirt it was warmer here but there
was a stuffy air that hit me hard in the
face I was still shivering as I wandered
inside my hands wrapped tightly around
myself as I headed in what looked like
dead trees are fused into the kevinwalls
thick branches stretched far and wide
they were ghastly things in themselves
shadowy thick said divisions that looked
like bones of skeletons scattered here
and there
chains were dangling from the ceiling
most of them rusted another stained and
dripping with fresh blood some of them
had cuffs and to my horror I could see
one that had a bloody hand trapped
inside a bit of bone just jutting out
from the rest I held him to my lunch and
walked quickly past avoided looking at
the hand at all cost
further up was an icy slope that looked
like it might have led somewhere but
even if I had shoes I still wasn't
climbing there it was calm to touch so
cold that I was afraid my tongue would
get stuck if I licked it not that I
would do something so silly I wanted to
climb it though I doubt Krampus could
fit inside the small crawl space and
even if it didn't lead anywhere it was a
place that I could hide there was
another bridge above me but this one
wasn't held together by rope they were
wooden beams that held it up from the
ground but the wooden rail above had
been smashed to pieces
barrels were littered at the base of the
stairway leading up to the bridge and I
had the urge to see what might have been
inside that was when I heard the sound
of scratching head Krampus found me
already I launched behind the barrels
dock down behind them and peered out
through the gap between something was
definitely coming
but sounded like it was coming down the
icy slope that I had seen the sound of
something grating against the ice was
accompanied by the cry of a woman and
then suddenly she came sliding up from
the slope crashing hard against the
floor I'd never seen her before she
looked scared
perhaps as scared as I was as she
glanced around the room of more than
just fear why she was remembering
something and didn't want to believe it
mom had always told me not to talk to
strangers and so with that in mind I
thought it was best to stay hidden her
hands were tied behind her back with
rope and she looked like she'd hit the
ground pretty hard of her face still she
wants around like a hawk rolling on the
ground as she tried to free herself [ __ ]
the woman hissed I started to feel like
the world is a lot more common than dad
would have me believe I noticed that she
didn't have any footwear either actually
she didn't have much clothing at all
except for grey shorts and a gray vest
there was a rope around her ankles that
I only just noticed and as far as I
could see she wasn't going anywhere even
though she rolled around like a mad
animal trying to break free maybe I
should have helped her straight away I
mean even though mom said not to talk to
strangers she would have wanted me to
help someone in need or didn't she but
then again I began to think why she was
tied up and why she was here in Krampus
is layer she must have done something
terrible
surely I must have crunched for a good
five minutes before she stopped
wriggling like a worm she roared ahead
through gritted teeth at nothing at all
she grew red in the face panting heavily
each one of her breath sound like a
motor it was only then when she was
completely quiet that I realized I had a
choice to make did I let myself be known
or was I better off sitting tight behind
the barrels hoping that Krampus would
never find me she managed to roll
herself over to the wall head down with
her hair covering her face [ __ ]
Krampus she muttered since when did he
start tying people up perhaps she was on
my side or at least against Krampus that
was the best thing I could hope for I
thought about trying to sneak past her
or maybe whether I should have just
bolted on it wasn't as if she could stop
me given that she was tied up the worst
thing about it all was I needed to pee
real bad but I didn't want to risk her
hearing me then what was I gonna do
pretend I couldn't see her are you just
gonna sit there are you gonna help me
she spoke to me my breath caught in my
throat but when I looked at her through
the gaps of the barrels I could see her
hair still covering her
I ducked down behind the barrels one
small trying to make myself as small as
possible how had she seen me know she
could have been talking to me she hadn't
even looked over here how would she have
known I was here I can hear your teeth
chattering she muttered as if she wasn't
interested at all it was only then that
I realized my teeth had been crunching
against each other you'd better come
over here and warm yourself up she said
before deciding on the piece of wood and
discarding the rest who are you I peered
out from behind the barrels she looked
up with a bridge and then glanced up at
the stairway following it up and across
I never wanted to come back here but
he's finally come for me who I forced
myself out from behind the barrel I
decided that she wasn't a scariest
Krampus but she did have a certain air
about her that made me not want to trust
her you haven't seen him yet she looked
to me of a cold set of dark eyes he's
the one who brought you here
Krampus I whispered she nodded what the
hell is he I asked she raised an eyebrow
at me then I can see how you ended up
here using language like that [ __ ]
I sighed only to see her eyebrow raised
even higher ah
I mean dawn swirl you like kid she
shrugged her shoulders it might be the
last chance you get what do you mean
I asked Krampus she stressed like yours
obvious he's gonna kill us unless we
escape his lair he's a vengeful creature
who never forgets anything even if we
managed to get out or he decides to let
you go he'll never forget I don't
understand I cried out if she glanced
away from me I must staring up at one of
the hanging lanterns on the wall kid she
started pointing with her chin bring us
down one of those lanterns it will keep
us warm I didn't want to point out that
I couldn't reach but I didn't want to
trust her either the fact that she was
tied up didn't mean much to me but there
was something about her something that
made me think it would take more than
just ropes to keep her really trapped
what the hell am I going to do of a
lantern she snapped at me and must have
realized I was suspicious of her if I
was going to hurt you I'd need to be
untied don't you think I guess I
shrugged and turned away to stare at the
lantern that was concealed by a dark
orange flame it was impossibly high
so impossible that I think even if I
jumped in swiped I still would have
missed it so I turned around to face the
woman with an apologetic smile in my
face for Christ's sake
she rolled her eyes untie me and I'll
get it down myself
I could make out her eyes now hidden
behind her dark hair while they want as
horrifying as a dark pits that were
Krampus his eyes they were still scary
but in a different way the woman didn't
look at me like she wanted to eat me or
harm me or do anything to me
in fact if I was honest she just looked
damn straight annoyed any time now she
held up her hands I approached
cautiously not just because of her but
because my foot was paining me
I found myself limping around the
shattered floorboards carefully avoided
in the spiky bloody nails and sharp bits
of wood that poked out here and there if
I untie you I stammered will you promise
not to hurt me
I promise she said now would you kindly
untie me I managed to yank at her
restraints until the rope from her
ankles was free as I did I could feel
her cold breast sliver and against my
neck and my hands she said as I got up
to walk away you don't expect me to
untie myself do you I didn't like how
she was looking at me she still seemed
annoyed but there was something else
shimmering in the depths of her eyes
even to this day I couldn't explain to
you what it was but her I spelled out
something to me something vague that had
me wanting to run away if you don't
untie me kid I can't protect you from
Krampus she told me I didn't want to
tell her that Krampus was a large thing
with horns and fur that she didn't stand
a chance against so I kept quiet I
thought she might have shouted at me if
I disagreed with her you want me to
untie you I asked her yes she hissed and
patiently uhm why should I
I challenged her her eyes widened as she
looked at me as if she couldn't believe
what I was saying
you already untied my feet kid you can't
just leave me like this
why not I asked because and she stopped
her leaning closer her voice low and
cold the demon lurks down here in the
icy depths of his lair he'll pull off
your legs rip off your arms need every
inch of you piece by piece there's only
one person who can save you from that
and that's me you want to face him by
yourself fine be my
guest I'll just sit here and watch as
Krampus devours every single okay okay I
cut her off I don't want to hear any
more maybe I can untie you
maybe she raised an eyebrow before
clearing her throat her voice was even
lower now as she called on her knees
towards me you'd better watch out he
better not cry better hide quick
otherwise you'll die Krampus has come
into town stop it I shouted at her he's
making a fist and clicking his wrists
gonna give you wounds they you need to
stitch Krampus has come into all right
all right I gave in I'll untie you it
didn't take me long to work on a knot
that had been tied and pretty soon the
Rope unraveled around her until she
snatched her hands-free was that so hard
I watched her for a few moments pacing
up and down glancing occasionally at me
the same way dad looked to me whenever I
did something wrong her skin had gotten
a bit more color she walked up and down
but she will still pale perhaps almost
as pale as a snow itself I looked down
at my blackened feet and wondered
whether or not I needed an adult hell I
heard her curse again as she began
scavenging amongst the bits of shattered
wood then she hold up a few of the
sharper bits of wood and was comparing
them to one another that was another
thing I wish I had done looked for a
weapon to fight back with are we gonna
die down here I asked her Shh she
stormed over to me dragging a lantern
off the wall she did you have to be very
quiet in this place if he hears us then
he'll come for us she made a hissing
sound of her teeth as she tossed the
lantern down to my feet and the warmth
was intoxicating and I found myself
sinking to my knees beside lapping up
the heat as much as I could
don't get too comfortable the woman told
me I can feel him he's near what even is
he I asked he's an associate of a man
named Nicholas the one you may know a
Santa he used to be a good man
who bought joying gifts to children as
you've been taught but throughout the
years Nicholas grew tired and bitter
after his wife died he turned to dark
magic and it corrupted his mind through
the dark magic that he practiced Krampus
was born a monster who preys on naughty
children who don't obey their parents it
wasn't the first time that evening and I
wish I hadn't sworn at all I wish I
hadn't gone against my father's
instructions and crept out of bed
I even regretted flipping off my sister
so why are you here I asked you're not a
child did Krampus bring you here yes she
nodded you're correct
I'm not a child but there's no time to
explain we need to go she grabbed me by
the hand and stormed ahead to want to
stay away but with my blackened feet I
couldn't keep up with her something she
soon noticed you don't look in a good
way kid she said to Versailles if we get
out of here I'm gonna have to drop you
off at a hospital but I hate hospitals i
shrieked and instinctively backed away
from her do you want to keep your feet
on not she reached for me but I stumbled
out of her grasp you can't leave me at a
hospital I shouted and didn't realize
how loud my voice had gotten I hated
hospitals I couldn't stand them not the
smell or the food or the people or
anything I can't exactly go in there
with you
she hissed and continued to try and grab
me do you know how bad that would even
look that I show up with you dressed in
my night wear with a child who has
frostbite they'll just throw me in jail
straight away but you didn't do anything
to me
I said they won't believe that she
replied I'll tell them that Krampus did
it then they'll think were both crazy
she scoffed now if you can't run then
I'm gonna have to carry you aren't I but
my mom said I shouldn't trust strangers
I said and realized that if I listened
to my parents more often I probably
wouldn't be in the situation I am right
now she rolled her eyes with a sigh fine
my name is Cass I work at a night club
in Austria I'm 32
I have no boyfriend and I'm probably
gonna die alone I have an extremely
severe deficiency in vitamin D and I
love cranberry juice now tell me
something about yourself I'm dumb I'm
ten years old and I've a sister named
Anya we live in Baltimore and there she
grabbed my hand we're hardly strangers
anymore are we
I shrugged either way I don't think I
had much of a choice as she lifted me up
into the air and lowered me onto her
back you're really strong hold on she
warned me as we started across the
bridge giddyup horsey
I said jokingly do not call me that
sorry I winced and kept quiet off of
that
we're almost there I told the boy whose
name I had already forgotten he hadn't
said anything in the 15 minutes that
we'd been running but I didn't blame him
when I was his age I had run this very
bridge myself with a demon hot on my
heels and I hadn't been in a talking
mood either almost there I said again a
few minutes later but I got the sense
that he had stopped believing me by now
his arms are tightening around my neck
as he squeezed tightly of his little
legs one of which was horribly dark the
two had certainly got to him but at
least he was quiet the last thing I
wanted was a sniveling brat on my back I
peered over the edge of the bridge as we
tore across it feed slamming hard into
the wood a rocky death awaited us below
should we have fallen
it was the same rocky death I'd seen
Krampus plunge to the last time I
encountered him but I imagined he'd be
wiser to my ploy this time a large crop
of rocky spikes stared at me from below
the same rocky spikes that stared at me
the last time I sent Krampus fall into
his demise there was dark red blood that
clung to those tendrils below staining
it like algae on a coastal rock room us
there I said again but I think both of
us knew I was trying to convince myself
more than was trying to convince the kid
Cass he spoke but he sounded weak all of
a sudden I don't feel so good I needed
to get him to a hospital
the best I could do was get him to the
ends of the bridge climb up the ladder
that I'd seen last time and then drive
him to a hospital maybe we wouldn't have
to face Krampus at all maybe I was
faster this time and he was back in his
lair scratching names off his naughty
list
stay with me kid I told him if you don't
and then you're gonna miss the story
story I heard him pick up a little odd
story about the last time I was here I
said panting as we ran do you want to
hear it yeah he nodded his head I must
have been about the same age as you I
began I was a little girl living in the
bustling city of Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
do you know where that is
no he shrugged it's next to Maryland
where you live like you my ended up in
Santa's naughty list what did you do he
asked a little more than swearing I
smoked as I thought back but I won't be
telling you that anyway
Krampus came for me on Christmas Eve
chasing me throughout my house as I
tried to get away I tried to make a lot
of noise to wake up my parents but it
was no use and they never heard me and
they were too interested in my little
brother my parents always to interest
my sister the boy remarked so you know
what I'm talking about then I noted when
Krampus took me I ended up here in his
lair but I guess that wasn't as brave as
you I was able to find shelter further
in a cavern where I snuck out
occasionally to steal lanterns in order
to keep warm how long were you here he
asked me three days I shuddered by just
saying it out loud three whole days of
hiding and running from him until all
one until I got to this bridge here how
did you escape him
I felt the boy look over his shoulder
and heard the breath catch in his throat
I knew what he had seen I tricked him
was all I said as I slowed to a stop it
was a shame to just the head I saw the
edge of the bridge and there dangling
from a snowcat platform was the same
rickety rope ladder that I frontally
climbed up all those years ago it
couldn't have been more than just 20
paces away and yet I knew in my gut and
there was no outrunning him now I heard
him grunt
I had to give it to Krampus my eternal
nemesis his girl Faust tremendous as he
walked like a hunchback crippled bent
over and struggling but he was
deceptively fast I had seen him leap
from one side of a gorge to another as
he went hunting for another kid who
ended up down here that was the thing
about him he brought us here but he
wasn't brave enough to just kill us no
he wanted us to feel fear first wanted
us to think that we were getting away
when in actuality we were just plain
right into his hand why'd you stop the
boy rocked on my back he's there he's
right behind us Cass a part of me wanted
to just make a break for it I'd seen one
kid try that the last time I was here
and even though he had fifty yards on
the creature it still caught up to him
I'd seen so many kids run from Krampus
and yet I was sure I was the only one
that got away that's why he still
haunted my dreams and that's why he
brought me back here the same way I
always knew he would Cass the boy pulled
at my hair and had half a mind to smack
him for that but then again how could I
blame him go go he urged me shoving at
my shoulder we can't outrun him I
grabbed him and lifted him off my
shoulder what do you mean he'll catch us
it's what he does he always gives the
kids a full start only so he can see the
disappointment and anguish in their eyes
when he finally does catch them I tried
to explain it as best as I could
but the boys face only reddened as his
lips began to curl let me go he tried to
wrench himself free raiven like a fish
dumped in lava I glanced over my
shoulder and saw my nemesis strolling
towards me like he had all the time in
the world truth was he did he swung one
of the birch sticks in his hand a long
gilded stick but looked more like it
belong behind the glass of a museum than
it did in his grasp he smoked his own
hand of it a few times during his
approach he had the nerve to adorn a
Santa hat on his head that said
precariously in between his two crooked
homes his face was sagging the gray skin
around his chinks seeping off him like
an age-old lumpy porridge there were no
ice our stare into just two dark empty
holes filled with crimson it was only
his mouth that gave away to what he was
feeling as his long grey tongue draped
down his hairy chin hungry Cass Cass the
boy shouted at me and that's when I
realized how I was going to outsmart
Krampus once again we can't outrun him i
hissed at the boy getting right up to
his face so he knew I meant business
honestly I thought the little [ __ ] was
about to break into tears right there
and then the color had drained out of
his face and I must have really stunned
him because he stopped shivering but you
can me he gulped what do you mean
there wasn't much time to explain as
Krampus thought he running towards us a
crazed screech escaped his mouth as he
lifted the birch stick above his head
already swinging it he's coming the boy
shrieked you'd better start running then
I told him as I shoved him away from me
he nearly fell over and I was worried
that he wasn't able to put any weight on
that foot of his but to his credit he
found his balance and moved more like a
dog for a few moments before hopping
onto one foot towards a ladder
Krampus must have realized what was
going on because he let out a frustrated
roar he shocked wildly with the birch
stick slashing at the sides of the
bridge completely deranged as he moved
towards me I lifted my fist for all the
good it would do Cass the boy cried out
behind me go I barked at him he can't
get us both now go I snapped and that
was the last thing I said to him I heard
him struggling with a ladder but there
was nothing I could do for him Krampus
would only need a few seconds with me
and while he usually played with his
food he would not be taking his time
with me not today not when someone was
about to escape I wondered if he
remembered
as he showed me his teeth roaring and
wailing like a demented fiend with an
itch he couldn't scratch I showed him my
teeth clenching my own so that he knew I
wasn't going to go down so easy no I'd
beaten him once I tricked him into
fallin off the bridge as he over swung
and went barreling over I could beat him
again somehow
I wanted to wait for her but my body had
other ideas
before I could realize I was halfway up
the ladder my arms moving on their own
accord as I pulled myself up my feet
heavier than usual and looking down at
the weird blackened skin I wondered if I
was going to be okay at all my other
foot was showing signs of turn into dark
veins spreading across my ankle and
starting to throb come and then you
bastard
Cass roared at Krampus I sucked in a
breath so hard I almost fell off the
ladder when I saw Krampus striking with
his stick Cass was faster though was
that was a lunch with a side ducking
around his giant back and striking him
hard in the kidney I wanted to stay
there and shake ass on but I was scared
that Krampus might hear me and come off
the me instead the monster groaned but
it looked like he would take more than a
single punch for him to go down he swung
around of a meaty arm and caught her in
the cheek Florin her without much hassle
at all
she was dazed for a moment but then she
spat blood beside her and quickly got to
her feet that all you got [ __ ] she
smirked but pulling down the side of her
mouth
Krampus screech at her and then lunge
forward at a frightening speed he lifted
he stick again and then down at her but
Cass caught it before it could hit her
there was a moment have struggled in as
the pair of them locked eyes wrestling
for the stick do then Krampus thrust his
fist forward catching her in the mouth
again her head worked back in Cass
stumbled backwards teetering dangerously
close to the edge as she staggered
against the rail she had her hands up
like a boxer but she was wobbling from
side to side one eye twitchin and the
other one read how hard he hit Cass I
couldn't quite say she knew how to take
a punch though but I didn't like her
chances of taking a second campus began
to laugh at her and I wanted nothing
more than to descend down the ladder and
fight him myself
but I was too afraid could you really
blame me I thought about telling my
parents right away that Cass was stuck
down here in this lair but how would I
even come back here would I have to wait
until next year
[ __ ] I said to myself as I climbed a
little higher and then a little higher I
couldn't save her even as I heard
Krampus strike her again I knew there
was nothing I could do I forced myself
to step upwards of the white light that
had appeared and tried not to listen to
Krampus as wet very fist that caught gas
in the face over and over again
but as I near the top I heard Krampus
grunt he didn't sound so sure of himself
all of a sudden especially not when I
heard the strangest sound escaped casas
mouth laughter gotcha again she growled
I looked down just in time to see the
pair of them go tumbling through the
rail I thought I saw Castor's legs
wrapped around him her arms gripped
around his head and her teeth sunk in
T's neck but it all happened so quickly
I don't know what I saw wood splintered
everywhere as they disappeared into the
darkness there were no screams no whales
no nothing just the sound of fabric
whooshing through the air followed by
the abrupt thought as they hit the rocks
below maybe I should have gone back to
make sure Cass wasn't dead even though
I'd seen how sharp the rocks were and
the sheer drop that led to them I should
have checked I guess I didn't want to
see blood or even see how mangled her
body looked as she hit the ground worst
of all I didn't want to see if Krampus
survived that would have made Cass a
sacrifice in vain if he was still there
Dustin of his fur and speed in his way
back up to me I forced myself up the
ladder hoping that maybe just maybe Cass
somehow made it as I ascended higher and
higher I will soon absorbed by the white
light ahead I couldn't see anything but
somehow I felt warm all of a sudden as I
kept on climbing suddenly I wasn't
climbing at all but instead walking I
tripped over something stumble to the
ground and tried blinking away the white
light as it surrounded me I began to
smell something a piney smell from the
tree in my living room and the scented
candles used by my mother
the white light began to fade around me
and there was a Christmas tree appearing
as if from nowhere next came my dining
table and the door to the kitchen as
well as the ceiling the walls and
everything in between the sofa emerge as
the white light was drained from the
room the windows were penciled in right
before my eyes and the curtains were
thrown on as if they were dropped from
above the television came next
then the crucifix that hunks were
proudly in the living room and even the
wooden coffee table that we put our feet
on I was home mom dad I shouted relieved
but they weren't there
they must have been upstairs sleeping
still I step forward and staggered
nearly falling flat on my face as my
feet betrayed me there was no feeling
left in my left foot and it was as black
as the night my right foot wasn't faring
any better was the bones in my toes
aching so bad that I thought they might
have fallen out
I touched them to see if I could rob
some feeling into either one of them but
the left one was just a useless bit of
flesh now and I suspect that the right
one wasn't far behind perhaps the state
of my feet was proof that I hadn't
dreamed to any of it that I had truly
been in that icy lair my parents had to
believe me I saw the cabinet was still
open and most of that booze was empty
bottles scattered on the table and some
pouring onto the floor dad would be mad
about that no doubt but it would only be
more proof of what I had been through
that night I thought about how Santa had
been so mean to me and whether or not I
wanted to keep believing in him perhaps
I didn't have a choice though he seemed
pretty real to me mom dad I called out
they had to know what I'd been through
what I'd seen I'd have to tell them
about Cass and how she was still down
there I didn't care what sort of trouble
I got into for being up so late I was
already in trouble for that there was no
punishment my parents could give me that
compared to an evening of Krampus mom
dad I shouted at top of my lungs I
didn't forward past the tree and even
past the presence that Santa left us I
wanted nothing from him never again
I crawled upstairs I didn't care what
sort of noise I was making this late in
the night my parents had to know what
I'd seen mom dad I stumbled into their
room off for heaven thrust open the door
I swung back against the wall ringing
out through the entire house I was sure
my dad would leap from the bed and come
storming at me for making an entrance
that loud at this time and evening but
he didn't he didn't even stir even my
mom who was a lighter sleeper of all
remained silent maybe because she was
extra tired I thought to myself as I
made my way to their bedside but there
was a simpler explanation they weren't
there I figured they must have been in
Anya's room they'll probably plane with
her again probably cut dinner and
holding her and having one big happy
sleepover while I wasn't there I rolled
up my sleeves I wasn't gonna stand for
that I've been through too much this
evening to allow my sister to upstage me
anymore
I barely made it into her room as I
crawled across the floor ripped off her
duvet and found nothing
arunya I looked to run the room but
there was no sign of my sister anywhere
my heartbeat began to quicken I didn't
like this feeling the feeling that I was
entirely alone everything seemed dark
all of a sudden as I struggled out of
our news room back down the stairs in
the blind hope of finding them all hided
behind this
maybe this was just one big prank and I
hadn't seen any of the clues on hands
and knees I sculpt back into the living
room moving past the fireplace only to
stop when I noticed my stocking on the
floor but everyone else has remained
hanging at least that was something I
could be thankful for I figured Santa
had not mine over in his drunken rage
but at least he filled theirs up with
candy I crawled my way over to the
stockings expecting to see them loaded
with treats but something other than
candy spilled out it was just lumps of
coal I pulled out the contents of every
one of them
frantically shifting through them as if
it would lead to some clue as to where
my parents were but the only thing that
came out was tiny fragments of Blackrock
I didn't understand why had Santa given
my family coal my mind was racing of a
thousand thoughts and none of them were
good I brought a shot of coal closer to
my face to examine only to remember the
dried scene full of coal and Krampus his
lair suddenly I realized where my family
were I looked down at the label in each
stocking and they're written in black
ink was one simple message greetings
from Krampus
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]